new Harris Poll found out that the
amount of US adults who believe in God
is declining and there was some really
other fascinating info on this as well
let's look at the findings seventy-four
percent believe in God which is down
from 82 percent in 2009 39 percent think
God is male 1 percent think God is
female I think that's kind of curious
we'll get to that
72% believe in miracles which is down
from 79 percent 68 percent believe in
heaven down from 75% 58 percent believe
in the devil and hell down from 62
percent 47 percent believe in Darwin's
theory of evolution up from 42 percent
in 2005 so just starting with the god
thing first I believe I have to atheists
at the table am I is that I'm agnostic
why I have an agnostic I've said before
I will say it again I've said it before
but there's something I am an atheist I
am so thoroughly an atheist when people
tell me they believe in God I don't
believe them the idea that people
believe in that kind of magical being
utterly baffling yeah I just don't get
it so then let's start with the god
stuff first so as an agnostic as and as
an atheist do you guys see this
basically as a good trend that people
are getting away from this sort of
notion of this supernatural being that's
watching you and judging you and really
cares about what you're doing with your
private parts okay there's no question
that a huge chunk of the population in
the u.s. still believes in in you know
puritanical ideology and Christianity
and in in dictating our lives based on
this magical book and it's definitely
sad but the numbers indicate a decline
and that's good news I think that more
and more people in younger generations
like Millennials for instance are much
more open-minded to an actual secular
society for one because we do have a
population that doesn't believe in a
secular society but also you see the
emergence of agnostics and atheists in
younger generations and I think that's a
good sign I think that we're gonna see
this trend continue as older people die
off let's keep it real right and and
younger people become a dull
and they push their ideology which is
this is complete and utter [ __ ] yeah
is there something a little worrisome
about this idea that these people have
to die off because even Oprah said that
a couple weeks ago remember she said
that the older racist they just have to
die off but is there so what do you
change them you can't change it but is
there something a little risky dangerous
assumption at the base of that which is
that just given free reign humanity will
always develop toward the better that's
what I think you know I don't think
there's a guarantee that we're never
going to return to the dark ages just
because the the believers die off now I
think a new generation could be trained
into stupidity with very little
difficulty to interrupt but I I mean
based on how things are going currently
in our in our current political system I
think that if the younger generation
remains or at least becomes more
politically active things will in the
country will change for the better
gay rights is one example of that right
I mean marijuana legalization is another
example of that and I think that it's
younger generations that are really
pushing for that so as long as that kind
of trend continues I think that the
country will get better on some issues
but here's the thing when I was a kid
and I know I am significantly older than
both of you put together
when I was a kid the peace movement was
taking off and the civil rights movement
was taking off and the women's movement
was taking off and we were all saying we
just have to wait for these old
conservatives to die off and
everything's going to be fine and then
there was backlash and there was Reagan
and there was voodoo economics and we
undermined our health care our mental
health system and women still make what
82 cents on the dollar to men and blacks
and Hispanics are still woefully
underemployed and and underpaid and
there is this pendulum swing that goes
on and yes I think it is good that right
at this very moment there's a decline in
hyper religiosity
among
this current generation but I don't
think that's going to continue without
constant pressure from the left and and
from the intellectuals the banking on is
the fact that people don't like to be
told what to do right we know you don't
want the government to come in to your
bedroom and tell you who you can and
can't have sex with you don't want the
government telling you which drugs you
can and cannot do so this you know
religion dictating our personal lives
and our personal behavior is something
that I'm seeing a little bit of backlash
towards so that's I guess that's what
I'm really banking on I think that
backlash is healthy and I think it's
good but I don't think on its own it's
going to do the trick it's very easy to
raise anti intellectual sentiments and
it happens in this country
periodically I Forrest Gump was a movie
about how we're gonna be very proud of
our nation's history if we can just
learn to see it through the eyes of a
[ __ ] and and it won all sorts of awards
and everybody loved it and said oh this
is genius and it led us right into what
is now the development to the Tea Party
and we just we have to be ever vigilant
against that guy and don't get me wrong
I try to be utterly respectful of
whatever superstitious [ __ ] people
want to believe in sounds that way but I
don't think it I don't think we can
trust that the country won't be run on
those ideas unless we really keep an eye
out for for the impending doom of
intellect in humanity yeah it's on its
way out well speaking of that so this
one percent of people that believe that
God is a woman that seems particularly
odd to me because if you're gonna go if
you're gonna have the leap of faith
saying I believe in something that can't
be proven it would seem to me that at
least women a higher percentage of women
would at least go out there and say and
at the same point I believe she's a
woman doesn't that seem if you're gonna
already make that jump like no one's
ever met God right like how do you know
what God looks like well like they would
argue that they have that they've had
some a lot of people would say you know
that they've had some experience where
they did meet
maybe didn't sit down at a bar with them
they were probably and like their brain
released some DMT system and they
thought that that you know that they saw
some sort of you know higher being I
don't know it's ridiculous like that
kind of [ __ ] pisses me off it pisses me
off almost as much as Fox News trying to
give Santa a race it's just so dumb well
that's exactly what I was thinking with
it to argue whether God is a man or a
woman is the same thing as saying
whether Santa's black or white it's
exactly people who believe all of this
people who believe in in the religious
view of the world are already so
thoroughly indoctrinated that whatever
imagery they were trained into holds
fast for them my favorite thing about
that was that it was 39% think it think
God is male 1% think God is female which
means like 60% think God is somewhere in
the LGBTQ range God is transitioning
yeah yeah God is currently taking the
hormones not yes yet fully what